hey wassup guys my name is a general
looked episode 53 of game program so
last time we took a look at this load
level method in the spawn level class
and today we're going to take a look at
converting level pixels and files so
yeah so generate level we made that mess
the last time and what that's gonna do
right is as you can see it doesn't
actually do anything in a level class so
that means that it's currently empty
completely something to do anything at
all what it needs to do right is
basically generate a list of tiles for
us so I've made it void here and the
reason I made it void is because we just
want to fill that array with tiles we
could have again a lot of people what
probably wondering I don't actually know
if a lot of people are actually
wondering this because I've been you
know the comments from yesterday's video
yeah but anyway the point is I could
have done something like this or I could
have even done something like this all
right but the reason I want to void is
because it's going to be way faster
versatile the second thing is I just
want to keep this tile rain tact so yeah
it wouldn't have been a bad idea to do
that but whatever yeah okay cool so
first of all our back in load level one
thing that I didn't actually do was set
the size of these tiles the size of
these tiles since the one pixel equals
one tile there will be as many tiles as
there are pixels and over here we have
both the width and height which is
awesome so what we can do here is just
simply set tiles equals to mute it equal
to new tile and then width times height
right because that'll be the amount of
tiles that we need there you go that's
how it's going to work
and in generate level this is where it's
where the stuff heats up here when you
decide which pixel we want to be which
tile so what color we want to be which
tiles so I'm gonna open paint.net
quickly just an empty paint net
human just to show you guys what I mean
so let's zoom in all the way so this is
big enough awesome so we could for
example black could be let's just make
black be like a wall right and then
let's make blue let's just say I don't
know what chatter blue let's just make
full blue be um I don't know well we've
got grass first well we'll make black be
like a wall or something but um we've
got we've got this green right we'll
make green
we'll make full green be let's just say
we'll make green be grass we'll make
full yellow be flower and then we'll
make sort of like a half yellow which is
seven f7f zero zero be a rock okay
literally just just for fun right now so
grass flower rock awesome so over here
in generate level now that we've got
we've got that information I'm gonna add
a comment a lot of you guys always ask
why I don't add way I don't add comments
and I'm gonna answer that question right
now
I don't add comments cuz this code is
damn simple there is nothing here worth
commenting the code that we've currently
typed in this series so far like I could
probably do in an hour or so by myself
without like any you know that like
confusing anything because this stuff is
really easy code when we get into like
harder more complex things which require
like an algorithm of operations or like
a huge mathematical calculation that you
know could be subject to error I'll add
comments there but here this stuff is
too easy to add comments for it's too
simple
there's no point like I wouldn't know
what comments to add cuz I do it's it's
written literally in English load level
you know generate level the other thing
I want to do here is add stuff like
color codes because I can't remember I
do I can remember them but I'm not going
to so first of all we decided the grass
would be just like so I remember
so grass is going to be Koran right
and green is what is great brain is
scrambled a that and we don't really
need that but well yeah put that because
that's how Java have the types of
decimals but that is obviously the
actual color let's say we made flour the
yellow which would be green and green
and red yeah it will be green right
wouldn't it I'm just like a friend right
I don't know yes it is um and rock was
like a medium red medium like a dark
yellow so those are the colors right
awesome so we have actually made the map
yet we'll do that next episode but um
today what a generative level so judging
by this I can say that if a particular a
particular pixel here in level pixels is
equal to a color then let's fill that
appropriate index of the tile array with
a grass tile
simple as that so basically what I'm
saying is first the first thing we're
going to do it like a for loop that
actually cycles for every single thang
so point y equals well now I didn't do
it that way
that'll be slow for in I equals 0 I is
less than tiles dot big better doing a
per square level pixels dot length
obviously they both should be the same
size but I mean it's probably result in
less crashes if we do level pixels
instead of tiles
since we're setting tiles not reading
and level pixels will definitely be an
appropriate size here
yep okay so let's um let's put that if
method inside here and all we'll do is
we'll say if tiles I sorry if level
pixels I is equal to obscure color so 0
X F F 0 0 for example and we'll actually
probably need to use that I'm not
actually sure we'll see just because we
all need an alpha channel live is that
for now what we'll actually will say but
if little cancels equals that color then
we will set tiles I equal to a new grass
tale all right
and I sorry I'm not new grass huh a tail
dot grass good the web fermented static
so that we don't have tons of instances
of the same tile that don't really need
to be instances and likewise you know we
alarm will do the same for all the other
colors so FF and then 707 F and so we've
great that would be flour and then that
will be wrong all right that's one way
of doing it and that'll basically
that'll work
totally so yeah awesome
so that will cycle through everything
every single one not sure how long that
would take
we'll take a look at performance in the
future but basically what that's going
to do is fill up this tile array with a
bunch of tile objects based on the
colors of these level of this level
pixel array integer array but yeah
other than that that is episode 53 of
game programming if you liked it please
the like button let us hit 100 likes
again and I'll see you guys in the next
episode where we'll move on with this so
yeah thank you guys
you